(Rires)
Pour nous, humains, qui sommes incapables de voler,
les oiseaux représentent la liberté.
Cette plume a permis aux oiseaux de vaincre la pesanteur,
et de voler dans les airs d'une manière extraordinaire.
Ne souhaitez-vous pas parfois pouvoir voler comme un oiseau ?
Les oiseaux sont ma passion.
Et je souhaite changer la façon dont chacun d'entre vous pense à eux.
La raison la plus simple pour laquelle je les aime tant, c'est leur beauté.
Il y existe 10 000 espèces d'oiseaux dans le monde,
et chacune d'elles possède une beauté particulière.
Les oiseaux sont extraordinaires
et cette conférence est dédiée à tous les oiseaux du monde.
(Rires)
(Applaudissements)
Certes, ces oiseaux ont fait partie de nos vies et de nos cultures
partout dans le monde, depuis des siècles.
Il existe une histoire d'oiseau dans chaque société.
Vous avez probablement écouté des contes d'enfants
sur différents oiseaux et leurs relations avec l'homme.
Personnellement, j'ai appris récemment que nos ancêtres
suivaient les groupes de vautours, lesquels les aidaient
à localiser les carcasses abandonnées par les grands carnivores.
Ces hommes recherchaient les carcasses et mangeaient une partie de cette viande.
Les oiseaux ont été utilisés dans marques et logos partout dans le monde.
Savez-vous que l'aigle chauve a été choisi pour l'emblème national des États-Unis
à cause de sa force majestueuse,
sa belle apparence, et sa longue durée de vie ?
Tout comme nous, humains,
qui avons réussi à vivre dans presque tous les habitats sur cette Terre,
les oiseaux ont aussi conquis le monde,
de ces magnifiques pingouins vivant sur les froides calottes glaciaires,
aux oiseaux tels que les alouettes,
qui survivent dans les déserts les plus chauds imaginables.
Vraiment, ces espèces ont conquis ce monde.
Les oiseaux construisent aussi des maisons, comme nous.
Les vrais pros de la construction
sont un groupe d'oiseaux nommé « tisserands ».
Ce nom leur a été donné en raison de la façon dont ils tissent leurs nids.
Chose intéressante,
les oiseaux ressentent de l'amour et flirtent tout comme nous, humains.
En fait, vous serez surpris d'apprendre
que les mâles s'habillent pour impressionner les femmes,
et je vais vous montrer comment.
Donc ici, nous avons un Euplecte à longue queue.
Voici à quoi il ressemble normalement.
Mais, quand vient la période de reproduction, tout change.
Et voici comment il apparaît.
(Murmures)
Vous voyez ?
Les oiseaux aussi - de multiples espèces parmis eux -
aiment toucher et câliner tout comme les êtres humains.
Et, je sais que vous vous interrogez à ce sujet...
Oui, ils s'embrassent également, parfois très langoureusement.
(Rires et applaudissements)
Certains ont même appris à tromper leurs conjoints.
Par exemple, le Jacana africain.
La femelle s'accouple avec plusieurs mâles.
Ensuite, elle part à la recherche d'autres mâles pour s'accoupler,
en laissant le mâle derrière, prendre soin des petits.
(Rires et applaudissements)
Les oiseaux nous aident tant !
Ils jouent des rôles très importants dans nos écosystèmes chaque jour.
Les vautours nettoient notre environnement
en digérant littéralement les agents pathogènes.
Ils finissent les carcasses qui, autrement,
coûteraient très cher à éliminer de l'environnement.
Un groupe appréciable de vautours
est capable de nettoyer jusqu'à l'os, une carcasse de la taille d'un zèbre
en environ une demi-heure seulement.
Les hiboux aident à débarrasser l'environnement des rongeurs
et cela nous aide en nous faisant économiser de l'argent,
car nous ne perdons pas nos récoltes
et n'avons pas besoin d'acheter de produits chimiques dangereux
pour gérer ces rongeurs.
Les beaux Nectariniidae que nous voyons autour de nous
font partie de la faune pollinisatrice dans la Nature.
Ils aident nos plantes à produire des fruits.
Avec d'autres pollinisateurs comme les insectes,
ils nous ont, en fait, aidés à obtenir la plupart des denrées
dont nous dépendons depuis des années.
Malheureusement, l'histoire des oiseaux est loin d'être parfaite.
Ils sont confrontés à de nombreux défis chaque jour, partout où ils vivent.
En tête de ces menaces se trouve la perte de leur habitat.
et la réduction de la nourriture disponible.
Les oiseaux sont aussi chassés, surtout les espèces migratoires
et les canards rassemblés autour des plans d'eau.
L'empoisonnement frappe les groupes qui aiment rester ensemble
surtout dans des endroits comme les rizières.
De plus, les lignes à haute tension électrocutent les oiseaux,
et les parcs d'éoliennes blessent les oiseaux quand ils traversent les pales.
Récemment, nous avons entendu parler du réchauffement climatique
qui fait souvent la une des journaux.
Il affecte aussi les oiseaux car ils sont forcés d'émigrer
vers de meilleurs sites de reproduction et nutrition
car malheureusement, l'endroit où ils vivaient est devenu inhabitable.
Mon propre point de vue sur les oiseaux a changé
quand j'étais jeune garçon au lycée.
il y avait ce garçon qui a frappé et blessé
l'aile et la jambe d'un oiseau appelé « Buse augure ».
J'étais là debout, à tout juste 14 ans,
et j'ai imaginé un être humain dans la même situation.
Cet oiseau ne pouvait pas s'en sortir par lui-même.
Donc, bien que je n'étais guère biologiste à l'époque,
je me suis uni à trois de mes amis
et nous avons décidé de loger l'oiseau jusqu'à ce qu'il retrouve ses forces,
et de le libérer ensuite.
Chose intéressante, il a accepté de se nourrir du bœuf de la cuisine de l'école,
et nous avons chassé les termites pour son dîner tous les jours.
Après quelques jours, il a retrouvé de la vigueur, et nous l'avons libéré.
Nous étions si contents de le voir battre des ailes
et s'envoler gracieusement.
Cette expérience a changé notre façon de voir les oiseaux.
En fait, nous avons décidé après ça, de créer un magazine,
que nous l'avons appelé le « Magazine de la Buse »
en l'honneur de cet oiseau que nous avions aidé
dans notre propre lycée.
Ces expériences au lycée ont fait de moi l'écologiste que je suis aujourd'hui.
S'intéresser aux oiseaux
devrait avoir une importance spéciale pour l'Afrique et tous les africains,
car parmi tous les autres continents,
l'Afrique accueille quelques-unes des plus étonnantes espèces d'oiseaux
que vous pouvez trouver dans le monde.
Imaginez avoir un nom comme « Bec-en-sabot »
qui est le nom de cet oiseau.
Certains pays comme la République Démocratique du Congo,
la Tanzanie, l'Ouganda et le Kenya
sont en tête du continent, avec le plus grand nombre d'espèces diverses.
Ces oiseaux continuent à fournir au continent
des services écologiques cruciaux dont l'Afrique a besoin.
De plus, l'Afrique a le potentiel de devenir un leader mondial
dans le tourisme aviaire.
L'économie en profitera certainement.
Imaginez le bénéfice que les communautés pourraient tirer des groupes de touristes
visitant leurs villages juste pour voir les oiseaux indigènes
qui ne se trouvent que dans ces villages.
Comment pouvons-nous, ensemble, aider les oiseaux ?
Vous avez tous la chance, aujourd'hui,
de transformer votre passion pour les oiseaux
en contribution à leur pérennité.
Et vous pouvez le faire en devenant un « citoyen scientifique ».
Les sciences citoyennes sont un courant grandissant dans le monde.
Dans certains contextes, les gens partagent des informations
avec le reste de la communauté sur les conditions de circulation,
les alertes de sécurité, etc.
C'est exactement ce que nous, observateurs d'oiseaux, avons réalisé.
Nous avons pensé, étant donné que les oiseaux se trouvent partout,
que si nous faisions que tous, ainsi que tout le monde en Afrique,
nous informent sur les oiseaux se trouvant là où ils vivent,
dans leur école, où là où ils travaillent,
nous pourrions être en mesure de créer une carte de chaque espèce.
Et, à partir de là, les scientifiques
pourraient concentrer leurs efforts de conservation
sur ceux de ces habitats qui comptent le plus.
Prenons par exemple ces deux projets,
l'Africa Raptor DataBank,
qui cartographie tous les oiseaux de proie du continent africain,
et la Carte des Oiseaux du Kenya
qui cartographie environ 1 100 espèces présentes dans mon pays, le Kenya.
Ces deux projets ont maintenant des bases de données en ligne
qui permettent aux gens de soumettre leurs données.
Ils ont été convertis en sites Web très interactifs
que le public peut utiliser, y compris pour prendre des décisions.
Au début, nous avons rencontré un énorme défi.
Nous avons reçu beaucoup de plaintes d'observateurs d'oiseaux disant :
« J'habite dans un village sans accès à l'ordinateur.
Comment puis-je te dire quels oiseaux vivent chez moi,
dans mon école ou là où je travaille ? »
Nous avons été obligés de changer notre stratégie et trouver une solution durable.
Cela a été facile.
Nous avons de suite réalisé que les portables
devenaient de plus en plus communs en Afrique,
et la plupart des régions pouvaient accéder au moins un.
Nous avons donc créé des applications pour téléphones portables
que vous pouvez utiliser sur votre iPhone et sur Android,
et nous les avons faites gratuites
pour tous les passionnés d'observation d'oiseaux.
Nous avons donc créé BirdLasser utilisée par la Carte des Oiseaux du Kenya,
et aussi l'African Raptor Observations
maintenant utilisée par l'African Raptor DataBank.
Cela a été une percée énorme dans notre travail,
et nous avons obtenu d'énormes quantités de données
de chaque observateur vivant dans les régions.
Grace à elles, nous avons réalisé que la science citoyenne est très puissante,
la raison étant que la science citoyenne est adaptative.
En fait, nous avons été capables d'inciter de nombreux observateurs
de commencer à partager leurs informations avec nous.
Au départ, nous ne savions pas que les oiseaux
pourraient être une ouverture pour la protection d'autres types d'animaux.
Fait intéressant, maintenant, dans le Musée Virtuel de l'Afrique,
nous avons des cartes pour les libellules et les demoiselles,
les papillons et les mites,
les reptiles, les grenouilles, les orchidées, les araignées,
les scorpions et, oui, nous cartographions même les champignons.
Qui aurait pu imaginer que nous cartographierions les champignons ?
Cela nous a montré qu'en effet, nous avons créé une communauté de personnes
qui se soucient de la Nature, en Afrique.
Je vous appelle tous ici à vous joindre à moi
dans la promotion dans vos communautés, de l'importance des oiseaux.
S'il vous plaît, discutez des oiseaux avec vos amis,
car nous sommes toujours enclins à aimer et prendre soin de ce que nous connaissons.
Passez quelques minutes de votre temps libre
quand vous êtes au travail, à l'école, ou peut-être à la maison,
à regarder autour de vous pour voir quels beaux oiseaux se trouvent là.
Venez nous rejoindre dans la science citoyenne,
et parlez-nous des oiseaux que vous trouvez dans les endroits que vous visitez.
Même plus simplement,
vous pourriez acheter à vos enfants, ou frères et sœurs,
une paire de jumelles ou un livre d'oiseaux,
et laissez-les simplement apprécier la beauté de ces oiseaux,
parce que peut-être qu'un jour, ils voudront prendre soin
de celui qu'ils connaissent et aiment.
Les enfants sont, en effet, notre avenir.
S'il vous plaît, apprenons-leur à aimer nos créateurs de plumes,
parce que l'amour des oiseaux peut être une vaste passerelle
pour l'appréciation de toutes les formes de vie dans la Nature.
Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)
Merci.